روحت كان الملك عبد الله وكان رئيس
الديوان وجلست انا وقال لي احكي لي شو الي
صار حكينا
حصل يعني كل القصه
كلهم مش موافق
فانا لمس انه عنده استعداد
قال لي انتظر انتظر بكره بنحكي معك
فعلا انا ثاني يوم
اتصلوا علي
وقالوا ما في مجال السبب الملك جمع ما
يسمى مجلس امن الدوله
المجلس الامن الدوله رئيس الحكومه ورئيس
البرلمان ورئيس الاعيان وقائد الجيش مدير
المخابرات ومدير الاستخبارات هذول مجلس
الملك لاتخاذ القرارات المفصليه فواحد من
الموجودين كان الله يرحمهم هذه المجانين
قال لي يعني الملك حكى احنا ودينا فلان
وبلغ الاخوان فقالوا له بدنا صوتي
قال فما كان من مدير المخابرات الله يرحمه
التاني الشوبكي
فيصل الشوبكي قال له يا جلاله الملك مراقب
العام الاخوان اليوم في الجرائد معبيها
هاي الجرايد نقول لا نقبل لا صوتين ولا
ثلاثه نحن بنتغيير صلاحيات الملك في
الدستور
فبدهم ياخذوا الصالحات وبدهم الغاء
المعاهده وبدهم وبدهم فانا يعني لما سمعت
هذا يعني شيء ثاني يوم بيطلع هو هذا كان
بيحكي كلام ثاني
بالملك لما سمع هيك قال خلص اذا خليهم
فكانت محاوله من الملك الحقيقه انه يجيبهم
ولهذا الملك عبد الله صار عنده قناه عامه
هؤلاء قد تغيره وهذا انا بكون بسبب بعض
الاشخاص اللي تولوا قياده الاخوان دون
وعيسى دون وعي حتى اسلامي كما يجب اصبحوا
اخوانكم مش اخوانكم لا يعني اخوان التيه
يعني اذا بدك تكون يعني المجموعات
وهذا انا حتى الى الان انا طرحت عليهم
مبادره بدناش اسم الاخوان لانه الاسم مش
هو الابره ما بدنا تكون جماعه تكون وجماعه
واحده سياسيه واللي بده يشتغل ديني عمل
ديني بحث خليه لحاله